all we have the victor of the battle who
is now leading the same field cup and
yeah well first he defeated the number
two player the then number two player
the live rankings in the world Wesley so
and now he's one-upped himself and
defeated the number one player in the
world Magnus Carlsen congratulations
first of all
Maxime this game was not clean
it was crazy what were you thinking as
you did all those maneuvers and you got
surround move 41 about that point he
start to look like Magnus was putting
you in a squeeze yeah you think my
position was very reasonable but at the
same time I underestimated at first our
present his grip on the queenside could
be because there's always these ideas to
put a night to b5 sometimes even the
king to be five of them LightSquared
bishop get exchanged and yeah I mean
this position is so Yin unusual that's
it's very this moment this dramatic
moment in the game when you took on g3
yeah I such hope d2 was just shocked
completely when you saw the Brooklyn on
g2 well I didn't see what he wanted but
it turns out he forgot that after Bishop
e2 hocus withers before f4 I mean at
four and you cannot take on it too
because I mean it sort of the Bishop e2
at first okay three were doing on the
spot but there's a f4 and he cannot take
the bishop because of 91 because I mean
Trust is the diagonal means inner for
the bishop the bishop on c1 that was the
blind spot the f4 interfering with the
bishop now we know because we were
wondering why he so rapidly went into
this line and he forgot about this move
that's exactly what a miss
absolutely so you
forcibly into this line and now there
were so many other variations right
around that point is after Bishop e2
does not draw anymore this is what's
ridiculous for my guess is that she was
not war simply I'm just better and I
mean before that of course I I miss
played one more for tea I mean 35 to 40
I don't know exactly because my position
was very not safe but I had a very nice
regrouping and then somebody have to
move for tea I just couldn't see what to
do against his threat so mmm
I mean I definitely miss played
somewhere around here once you got the
edge did you you played so fast it
looked like you just knew that this
ending was just easily winning well it
was not easily winning coming are not
true but maybe after before I have to
play c4 but that was before I was the
key move yeah you started solving all
these problems we were very surprised
the way you just like you just knew this
setup you were going for because it
looked less like like calculation and
more like you just clearly know that
this setup was just winning well I was
not hundred percent true but I just have
a choice simply I mean I I don't know
was I ever simple way of going when we
get to this Bishop against Knight and
game but I mean whatever I was going to
do it was for instance if I go King f6f
or it gets King on d2 d1 I don't know
Bishop on you know King on sit to you
and Bishop before and yeah you always
get this concept egg against the pawn on
h5 if I try to go for the Queen side so
I mean it was just crazy position but I
mean still a crazy position but I
thought I'm gonna pick h4 and if it's
not winning yeah so be it but of course
I mean could have
banana doesn't surprised because I
didn't notice before and I was lucky to
find c4 of course there look some would
say skill to find such a move so quickly
you can you're in a confessional around
move forty and you looked like you were
too happy with your position at the time
and now it's all turned around and
before this tournament you said I'd
asked you about the event and you said
that this one is really important for
you because you've never won a super
tournament clear what does it feel like
right now to be in clear first place and
it seemed Philco I mean it's good but
well let's not get ahead of ourselves
that's for sure I mean night was a very
long time in game and unfortunately
Thursday is not tomorrow so tomorrow you
got your hands full with one Levon
Aronian he has a good friend of yours
but you guys do battle whenever you play
we see that you have a small edge on him
a five-to-four with 12 draws what are
the kinds of and oh and he mentioned by
the way before on the air he said when
you win it's usually that he blunders in
one move and when he wins is usually a
positional masterpiece what's your take
on that assessment well I'm thinking
about the games there was a couple of
good games that I won and to be very I
mean if first was beating zero against
me
and so my changes I want made it to five
three and lost the last decisive game we
played against each other I mean but I
mean I must admit I mean a couple of
nice games of him against me and but I
also also had some some good games and I
mean I remember one of his win actually
I mean it was just a crazy position but
completely displace from him so you know
I mean I think he he likes to
yeah no I mean - no I don't oh yeah
never mind what I was gonna say looking
for the English word or what is it yeah
yeah I'm be near in front but I no idea
yeah I don't know this right either yeah
it's well this guy's yeah well we know
that you guys enjoy each other's company
sure but tomorrow you'll have a war on
your hands as you're in first place in
the sink fell Cup very good position to
be in and we wish you the best as you go
forward with your dream
thank you mice thank you